[Musique]
LCP Assemblée Nationale en partenariat
avec MGEN mutuelle santé prévoyance
présente état de santé
[Musique]
travailler en souffrant d'une douleur
vive ce n'est souhaitable pour personne
alors quand cela revient chaque mois
comme les règles douloureuses c'est
invivable
l'Espagne est certain employeurs en
France comme la mairie de Saint-Ouen ont
donc décidé de proposer aux femmes une
solution le congé menstruel la parole se
libère peu à peu sur ce sujet qu'on
préférait taire jusqu'à lors
j'espère vraiment que ça puisse rentrer
dans la normalité en soit c'est nous
écouter enfin car ces douleurs de règles
sont rarement prises au sérieux ni par
les médecins ni par la société en
général dès qu'une femme se plaint en
attendant sa pensée à l'exagération qui
dit exagération dit c'est forcément dans
sa tête qui disait dans sa tête cette
hystérique
alors si le congé menstruel est un signe
positif de changement des mentalités
est-il dans les faits une bonne ou une
mauvaise idée c'est le thème de ce
nouveau numéro d'état de santé
[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans cet
état de santé une fois n'est pas coutume
on va aujourd'hui poser un débat pour ou
contre pour ou contre le congé menstruel
pour les femmes un congé pour les règles
douloureuses c'est une idée qui fait son
chemin en Espagne très officiellement en
France aussi il y a deux employeurs qui
ont d'une certaine façon franchit pas il
y a la grande chaîne de distribution
Carrefour qui a annonçait qu'elle allait
le faire pour ses employés ses salariés
et également la mairie de Saint-Ouen
c'est intéressant on va vous donner des
éléments évidemment pour vous faire
votre opinion grâce au docteur Bousseau
CAPMAS bonjour à vous merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous en quoi les règles
douloureuses sont un handicap au travail
bonjour donc c'est un handicap au
travail parce que c'est une douleur
permanente qui revient tous les mois
qu'on appréhende en plus quelques jours
avant qu'elle arrive et qui provoque
déjà chez les toutes jeunes filles de
l'absentéisme scolaire et qui continue
après dans servi dans leur vie
professionnelle à être handicapante avec
parfois des femmes qui font des malaises
qui font qui peuvent avoir des nausées
ou des vomissements suite à ces douleurs
et donc c'est vraiment vraiment
handicapant alors dans votre exercice
professionnel vous recevez souvent des
femmes qui sont victimes de ce type de
douleur quel est votre parcours quel est
votre fonction votre poste exactement on
regarde votre portrait
[Musique]
Perrine Gousseau CAPMAS et chirurgienne
et gynécologue obstétricienne à
l'hôpital Bicêtre APHP lorsqu'elle n'est
pas au bloc elle enseigne cette
spécialité à l'université Paris-Saclay
engagé contre les inégalités d'accès aux
soins elles mènent des travaux de
recherche à l'INSERM dans le centre de
recherche en épidémiologie et santé des
populations elle se penche notamment sur
la prévention la santé sexuelle et sur
la question du genre dans le système de
soins
[Musique]
docteur
c'est tabou les règles et en particulier
et un qualificatif qui est quand même
encore très associé aux règles et c'est
quand même incroyable c'est la c'est
sale les règles c'est sale pourquoi ça
vient d'où
alors ça vient d'où c'est probablement
parce que il y a du sang donc quand il y
a du sens et sale souvent après ce tabou
c'est un tabou sur la santé de la femme
en général c'est un tabou c'est un tabou
qui est issu probablement de cette
société patriarcale dans laquelle on vit
et où en fait tout ce qui est différent
du modèle masculin et
tabou les règles c'est vrai que on a du
mal à en parler au travail un exemple
criant de témoignage d'une femme dont je
taire et le nom mais qui racontait que
dans une réunion avec le directeur
général etc etc au moment où elle s'est
levée de sa chaise il y avait une tâche
de sang sur sa chaise et donc là elle
était pas bien mais l'ensemble du des
gens de la réunion était malaisé et tout
le monde est parti sans faire trop de
commentaires c'est alors c'est très
privé c'est vrai on peut dire c'est
tabou parce que c'est aussi l'intimité
de la femme en tout cas c'est vrai que
c'est un phénomène complètement naturel
je vous posais la question parfois ces
règles sont très douloureuses pourquoi
on regarde l'infographie
[Musique]
bouillotte tisane ou antidouleur chacune
son arme mais pourquoi les règles
peuvent-elles être douloureuses ces mots
semblent si banales aux yeux de
nombreuses femmes qu'elles ne se posent
pas la question et les médecins
eux-mêmes n'ont pas encore trouvé de
réponse satisfaisantes ce qu'il
soupçonne c'est le rôle joué par une
hormone
chaque mois l'utérus se prépare à une
éventuelle grossesse la muqueuse utérine
s'épaissit pour accueillir un ovule
fécondé s'il ne l'est pas il ne
s'implante pas la couche superficielle
de la muqueuse se détache alors et est
évacuée par le vagin pour se faire des
substances libérées dans le sang stimule
la contraction de l'utérus ce sont ces
hormones appelées prostaglandines qui
peuvent être à l'origine des douleurs il
y aurait même une relation directe entre
leur quantité et la sévérité des
symptômes
néanmoins d'autres facteurs pour
expliquer les douleurs abdominales
ressenties pendant les règles et même
avant lors de la phase prémenstruelle
une étude de 2016 réalisée auprès de
3000 femmes américaines mettez ainsi en
évidence une forme d'inflammation chez
celles qui souffrait de symptômes
prémenstruels
depuis 2016 la recherche a peu avancé à
en croire le nombre d'articles publiés
sur le site PubMed en 2022 elle
s'intéresse davantage aux
dysfonctionnements érectiles
codisménorrhée
les premiers touchent pourtant moins
d'un homme sur 5 contre 9 femmes sur 10
pour les douleurs de règles
[Musique]
docteur gousse au CAPMAS un trouble de
l'injection c'est un drame il faut tout
de suite le régler cette séance tenante
bon les règles douloureuses c'est pas
comme ça il y a un vrai contraste là il
est intéressant de s'y arrêter c'est le
contraste d'une société qui a été qui a
été mise en place de manière très
patriarcale et un problème qui touche
l'homme à la recherche va s'en emparer
rapidement alors que les problématiques
plus liées aux femmes c'est différent
puis là on est en plus pas dans
n'importe quel problématique masculine
les troubles de l'érection c'est en plus
le symbole de la virilité voilà là où
les règles c'est ça les donc pour le
coup on mettrait bien ça sous le tapis
le trouble de l'érection c'est un sujet
noble et donc il faut probablement s'en
emparer plus rapidement penser qu'il y a
encore des jeunes filles qui découvrent
ce que sont les règles sans avoir été
prévenu sans avoir eu d'éducation à cela
malheureusement oui aujourd'hui on est
censé avoir de l'enseignement
de l'éducation sexuelle dès la
maternelle alors à chaque âge ces
problématiques mais c'est censé évoluer
au fil des années normalement il est
censé avoir trois interventions par an
dans le milieu scolaire qui sont
largement pas faites ou insuffisamment
faites enfin c'est pas d'abord dans la
cellule familiale que ça doit se faire
franchement mais il y a encore des
milieux où on ne parle pas de ça c'est
d'abord qu'il faut intervenir non ouais
mais alors là on a moins de leviers que
vit à l'école c'est à dire que via
l'école on a des leviers sociétaux alors
que dans les familles on c'est presque
de l'ingérence d'ailleurs ce qui se
passe dans les familles et donc bah oui
parce que les tabous se transmettent
évidemment une femme qui a vécu ça comme
un traumatisme pour ne pas avoir été
prévenu de ce que ça représentait peut
reproduire le schéma avec sa propre
fille tout à fait en ce qui peut
contribuer à lever le tabou en général
c'est évidemment que ça soit plus
banalisé en tout cas qu'on puisse en
parler de façon plus naturelle dans le
milieu professionnel justement donc dans
cette mérite Saint-Ouen je citais tout à
l'heure ou un congé menstruel pour les
règles douloureuses va être accordée
comment ça se passe comment ça a été
conçu reportage Marianne Cazot
[Musique]
parler de menstruations dans une réunion
professionnelle c'est pour le moins
inhabituel ce sera certainement plus
courant dorénavant
bonjour à la mairie de Saint-Ouen
la municipalité vient tout juste de
mettre en place un congé menstruel
les modalités d'application sont encore
en débat à la direction générale des
Ressources Humaines
donc on avance également sur les
questions des critères médicaux pour
pouvoir objectiver au plus le traitement
des situations les collègues qui ont des
règles douloureuses associées à une
pathologie reconnue sur le plan médical
peuvent bénéficier des autorisations
spéciales d'absence pour les autres
collègues on a d'autres mesures à
proposer et il faudra voir quelle
coordination est prévue en termes de
service de santé au travail c'est qui
intervient est-ce que c'est la concert
de prévention ou systématiquement la
médecine du travail ici personne n'en
doute ce sujet intime à toute sa place
dans le monde professionnel
54% des agents menstrués ont des règles
dites incapacitantes et que ce chiffre
là à lui seul il est éclairant pour se
dire que on ne peut pas passer à côté
il faut dire que le poids du tabou peut
être très lourd à porter
cette jeune femme qui préfère rester
anonyme cache autant que possible ces
crises d'endométriose au travail dans
son entreprise de restauration rapide
pour tenir le rythme elle prend des
antidouleurs mais elle se sent
aujourd'hui au pied du mur je suis un
poids pour la j'ai l'impression d'être
vraiment un poids pour l'entreprise de
toute façon c'est un peu ce qu'on fait
ressentir
bon en fait je peux rien faire j'ai même
avec les cachets etc la douleur passe
pas malgré mes traitements donc la
pilule etc ça ne passe pas et
je sais que je suis comprise par mon
gynéco mais j'ai pas l'impression d'être
comprise après de grands mondes ne
serait-ce que que mes collègues et mon
patron justement je peux je suis
totalement démuni face à la situation
son employeur pourrait la licencier pour
inaptitude alors en plus de ces
symptômes physiques la jeune femme
s'inquiète pour son avenir une double
peine dont la mairie de Saint-Ouen
espère libérer ses agents municipales
comme Tanina Hull Younes
elle aussi a connu les réunions sous
antidouleur elle aussi a dû poser des
jours de congés parce qu'elle ne pouvait
tout simplement pas se lever du lit elle
aussi a souffert de ne pas être prise au
sérieux
c'est pas des sujets qu'on a forcément
envie d'aborder avec tout le monde donc
là le fait de que ça rentre dans le
vocabulaire commun et dans la liste de
jours de congés possibles et de
réorientation de travail comme ça on
voilà ça libère la parole et on passe à
autre chose enfin voilà faut que ça
vraiment moi j'espère vraiment que ça
puisse rentrer dans la normalité dans le
quotidien des dans Gestion des
Ressources Humaines ça se fait c'est pas
très compliqué et en soi en soi c'est
nous écouter enfin on nous écoute pas
beaucoup
la mise en place du congé menstruel et
pour elle une forme de reconnaissance de
ses douleurs si longtemps minimisé et un
bon moyen de lever les tabous qui
entourent les menstruations en général
mais
connu ça le truc côté là tu as ton temps
pendant une main ah il y a pas de
poubelle dans les toilettes machin ça
fait longtemps que le truc ça serait un
truc de mec et le tampon il serait
biodégradable dans les toilettes comme
le PQ quoi tu vois non mais c'est vrai
que c'est des trucs où tu devrais même
plus avoir honte de ça
et tu vois je pense même que ça va
permettre de déconstruire plein de
choses le délire de dire qu'est-ce que
tu as tes nouveautés de mauvaise humeur
tu as intérêt que bah et ouais et alors
parler plus ouvertement des
menstruations au travail pourrait donc
profiter à toutes la mairie de
Saint-Ouen réfléchit aussi à mettre des
protections hygiéniques à disposition
dans les toilettes des femmes
[Musique]
docteur gousse au CAPMAS est-ce que vous
êtes pour la généralisation
d'un congé pour les femmes c'est
difficile d'avoir un avis tranché je
pense qu'il y a du bien et du moins bien
comme dans toute comme dans toute
nouveauté le bien c'est effectivement
d'en parler de lever le tabou de
d'accepter que qu'effectivement les
femmes puissent avoir des moments où
elles sont pas elles sont pas peut-être
à travailler mon inquiétude c'est ce que
va pas y avoir une discrimination à
l'emploi on voit déjà parfois des
discriminations sur le risque de
grossesse à venir et de congé maternité
est-ce que si maintenant on rajoute
cette idée qui aura en plus peut-être un
congé menstruel
c'est un peu c'est un peu une inquiétude
que j'ai après je sais pas si elle est
fondée ou pas donc qu'on soit comment se
congés d'ailleurs c'est un jour deux
jours trois jours quatre jours le temps
que la femme dise qu'elle a plus mal ben
c'est toute la question c'est comment on
conçoit ce congé et puis comment il
fonctionne est-ce qu'il y a des jours de
carence parce que si c'est un jour par
mois mais qui a un jour de carence
comment ça marche enfin ça il va falloir
vraiment se poser la la question en
termes de mise en place réelle de
comment ça marche et ce qu'il faut faire
quelque chose qui s'appelle le congé
menstruel ou est-ce qu'il faut donner
aux hommes et aux femmes quelques jours
par an qui peuvent prendre un peu quand
ils veulent et que les femmes puissent
l'utiliser à ce moment-là et que les
hommes puissent l'utiliser je sais pas
sur la base d'un certificat médical
néanmoins en fait c'est une vraie
question c'est à dire que le certificat
médical ça oblige de trouver un médecin
qui va pas dire c'est normal d'avoir mal
au ventre pendant vos règles si on est
face à un médecin comme ça finalement le
congé menstruel on n'y aura jamais droit
normalement un congé
pour maladie c'est cliniquement quand
même constaté par un médecin alors c'est
cliniquement constaté par un médecin là
effectivement c'est c'est rapporté c'est
à dire que on a aucun moyen de de savoir
il n'y a pas de test il y a pas d'examen
pour dire que des règles sont
douloureuses c'est complètement
déclaratifs après on a un moyen
d'évaluer la répercussion sur la vie
quotidienne en évaluant notamment
l'intensité des douleurs en évaluant
notamment s'il y a des symptômes
associés je vous parlais tout à l'heure
de femmes qui des malaises qui ont des
nausées des vomissements ça on peut le
rechercher mais on a aucun test qui nous
confirme que qu'il y a des douleurs de
règles donc et puis alors parce que
comment faire toutes les femmes
pourraient considérer parce qu'elles ont
des règles même si elles sont pas
douloureuses
ben elles peuvent elles peuvent avoir
droit à ce congé c'est compliqué la mise
en place alors c'est compliqué mais je
pense qu'en France on a toujours cette
angoisse de de ceux qui vont l'utiliser
à mal et on fait pas confiance en fait
c'est-à-dire que est-ce qu'on peut pas
faire confiance aux femmes de se dire
que c'est le compas mal elles vont
travailler et celles qu'on mâle elles
vont pouvoir profiter de ce congé là
c'est c'est une vraie question après la
question des médecins derrière c'est
qu'il y a aussi un nécessité de
formation des médecins pour pour qu'ils
soient attentif à ces douleurs et qu'on
arrête de les banaliser en tout cas vous
votre première réserve votre principale
réserve c'est le risque de
discrimination c'est à dire
qu'effectivement c'est un caractère un
peu intrusif
ce congé quand on a un congé maladie on
doit pas dire pourquoi c'est un secret
ça relève du secret médical et là là il
y a un risque quand même qu'il y ait une
forme d'intrusion c'est ce qui
m'inquiète parce qu'effectivement on
rompt le secret médical dans la mesure
où on parle de congé menstruel et puis
après on rentre beaucoup dans l'intimité
des femmes c'est à dire que quand tous
les mois une femme à son congé menstruel
le jour où elle le prend pas ça veut
dire quoi qu'elle est enceinte donc elle
a plus de règles donc ça veut dire que
l'employeur il doit se préparer au congé
maternité dans 6 mois
ah oui en fait on entre dans la vie
privée des femmes on y a vraiment après
j'ai pas de meilleure solution à
proposer donc
on va être enceinte ça faut l'oublier
mais il y a des abus tout ça contribue
quand même tous ces débats que on a sur
la place publique et c'est nouveau
contribue quand même à la meilleure
prise en charge de ce type de pathologie
encore faut-il arriver à bien les
dépister correctement reportage de
Marianne Kazu qui a rencontré des
médecins qui cherchent justement à
améliorer le dépistage
[Musique]
9 femmes sur dix ont des règles
douloureuses mais une grande majorité
d'entre elles souffrent en silence et
c'est assez femme qui ne consulte pas
que François Marguerite a décidé de
s'adresser mais comment les faire venir
jusqu'au cabinet médicaux pour y
parvenir ce gynécologue obstétricien
s'est lancé dans une thèse
d'épidémiologie pour mieux définir le
public cible il a découvert que 40% des
femmes souffraient de douleurs
menstruelles ou disménorrhées modéré à
sévère une prévalence largement
sous-estimée
ces femmes qui présentent des symptômes
douloureux finalement se voit un peu
exclu de se dépistage qu'on a voulu
centrer sur l'endométriose qui a été
très bien et qui a un peu éclipsé ce
phénomène de dysménorrhée alors que on a
des traitements simples des traitements
qui marchent les campagnes de prévention
contre l'endométriose ont tout de même
permis d'érodé le mythe des règles
douloureuses mais il faut aller plus
loin quelle douleur doivent pousser à
consulter exactement pour le savoir
François Marguerite compile les données
car le seul critère de l'intensité ne
suffit pas la fréquence des
dysménorrhées les douleurs associées et
surtout les conséquences sur le
quotidien ont elles aussi leur
importance
le doctorant ainsi mis au point un
questionnaire détaillé pour un dépistage
dans les universités notamment
mais encore faut-il que les médecins
prennent les douleurs des femmes au
sérieux ce qui n'est pas toujours le cas
valerytis en sait quelque chose après 15
ans d'errance diagnostic je vous ai
aujourd'hui la chance d'être suivi par
une spécialiste de la douleur
bonjour Alors vous vouliez me voir
pourquoi
Delphine l'huilerie écoute ses plaintes
avec attention encore une fois
qui s'est déclenchée avec des
saignements pour commencer et puis
derrière tout un épisode digestif avec
le ventre très très gonflé douloureux et
dur et des douleurs derrière et aussi
des douleurs comme je vous en avais déjà
parlé de type coup de poignard
l'algologue insiste toujours sur un
point alors avant toute chose mais ça je
vous l'avais déjà dit je crois bon votre
douleur elle est pas dans la tête on est
d'accord dès qu'une femme se plaint en
attendant sa pensée à l'exagération qui
dit exagération dit c'est forcément dans
sa tête qui dit c'est dans sa tête cette
hystérie donc on a se rapprochement qui
a toujours été et qui a même montré sur
certaines études que le premier
traitement que l'on donne à un homme
quand il vient aux urgences pour une
douleur c'est un antidouleur et pour une
femme c'est un anxiolytique quand c'est
un homme alors on le croit quand c'est
une femme on la croit moins et c'est ça
qu'il faut déconstruire essentiellement
d'autant plus que cette idée reçue
retarde la prise en charge des patientes
comme valérytis les douleurs non
traitées s'installe et deviennent
chroniques donc en premier lieu quand on
saigne inflammatoire ça peut nécessiter
des anti-inflammatoires et puis il va y
avoir cette conséquence sur les nerfs
vous allez avoir une douleur névralgie
qui va se manifester à type de coup de
poignard et puis derrière on va voir un
cercle vicieux coup de poignard ce nerf
irrité va entraîner une perte de
mobilité de vos tissus digestif pelle
vient même lombaire et tout issu
élastique qui s'arrête de bouger les
muscles les tendons les ligaments vont
se rétracter de venir douloureux
d'accord et quand ça s'arrête de bouger
ça coince encore plus le nerf donc on a
ce cercle vicieux entre les deux et puis
tout ça va s'envenimer éventuellement
remonter à votre cerveau puis comme ça
se passe la nuit on est toujours un peu
plus anxieux le cerveau va finir de
faire exploser le système je vais faire
il existe pourtant contre ces douleurs
des solutions médicamenteuses ou non
comme l'ostéopathie ou la sophrologie
absolument
en attendant une meilleure formation des
médecins certains professionnels de
santé préfèrent prendre les devants en
sortant le savoir des cabinets médicaux
Anne roi et sage-femme à domicile afin
de viser un public le plus large
possible elle troque régulièrement son
matériel médical pour son outil favori
la vulgarisation scientifique
bienvenue dans tout sur elle aujourd'hui
nous allons parler de cette incroyable
organe qui est l'utérus à tous les âges
de la vie de la puberté jusqu'à la
ménopause quand les femmes ou les hommes
d'ailleurs sont informés de leur propre
santé ils deviennent les principaux
chefs de leur santé et c'est à eux de
nous driver c'est à eux driver les
professionnels de la santé pas l'inverse
c'est pas les professionnels de santé
qui doivent vous driver moi j'aime bien
avoir des des femmes qui me qui ont de
la répartie qui me disent mais moi je
pense ça je suis pas d'accord avec vous
Anna ok ça me dérange pas c'est pas
parce que je détiens à savoir que je
suis au-dessus d'elle ainsi elle espère
que les femmes ne laisseront plus
personne minimiser leurs symptômes avec
en ligne de mire un meilleur dépistage
des douleurs de règles
[Musique]
à quel moment conseillez-vous aux jeunes
filles ou jeunes femmes de consulter
quand elles ont mal ah bah dès qu'elles
ont mal parce qu'en fait c'est pas
normal d'avoir mal au ventre pendant ses
règles donc ça n'est pas normal d'avoir
mal au ventre et quand on est face à un
médecin qui considère et qui vous dit
c'est normal tu es une femme vous êtes
une femme font passer par là c'est
insupportable ah oui c'est un
supportable il faut chercher des
solutions après on en a pas toujours
mais il y a aussi un accompagnement
c'est pas uniquement de donner un
médicament un antalgique une pilule
c'est aussi de d'accompagner les femmes
dans ce parcours là de les écouter de
c'est très bien dit dans l'émission par
la médecin algologue qui explique
qu'elle prend en compte cette douleur
qu'elle l'écoute et que déjà ça et les
femmes le disent déjà le fait d'être
écouté c'est déjà une porte qui s'ouvre
donc il y a vraiment cette notion
d'accompagnement il n'y a pas que des
médicaments il y a aussi des médecines
dites alternatives et qui peuvent tout à
fait tout à fait prise en compte c'est
je pense que c'est vraiment ensemble
qu'on a réussi à soulager ces douleurs
mais déjà ne serait-ce qu'en écoutant
les femmes ce qui est intéressant aussi
dans le reportage donc c'est le fait que
lorsqu'un homme se plaint d'une douleur
hop on lui donne tout de suite un
médicament efficace un antalgique
lorsque c'est une femme on lui donne un
anxiolytique c'est vrai c'est
statistiquement établi alors c'est
statistiquement établies qu'on donne en
tout cas des antalgiques plus forts aux
hommes qu'aux femmes toutes choses
égales par ailleurs donc les femmes se
voient plus souvent prescrire des
antalgiques de paliers 1 là où les
hommes vont se voir prescrire des
antalgiques plus forts de pallier deux
ou trois après effectivement il a été
montré que on prescrirait plus
facilement des anxiolytiques aux femmes
c'est quoi l'idée c'est que c'est dans
la tête elles ont mal dans la tête
probablement l'idée c'est ça c'est que
c'est de l'angoisse c'est que c'est mais
ça a été montré dans dans de nombreux
domaines en cardiologie notamment par
rapport à l'infarctus du myocarde il a
été aussi montré que une femme on lui
donne des anxiolytiques là où on fait un
ECG pour rechercher un infarctus chez un
homme donc c'est en 2023 c'est toujours
le cas c'est toujours vrai il y a de
plus en plus de des gens qui essayent
d'en parler pour que justement ça évolue
mais mais en 2023 c'est toujours vrai
vous avez voulu poser une question comme
c'est la règle dans cette émission à un
élu de l'Assemblée nationale et en
l'occurrence Sandrine Rousseau dont on
connaît les positions très féministes
qui est députés du groupe écologiste
Nuxe à Paris et qui travaille sur une
proposition de loi qui est soutenue par
Sébastien Petavy pour instaurer un congé
menstruel en France vous lui demandez
comment faire en sorte que ce ne soit
pas soumis à l'appréciation d'un médecin
quand on sait vous l'avez déjà évoqué
que certains médecins considèrent que
c'est normal d'avoir mal au ventre
pendant ses règles et vous lui avez fait
part de votre peur de la discrimination
voilà sa réponse
[Musique]
le processus est pas arrêté mais la
manière dont ça se présenterait ce
serait 14 jours par an utilisables comme
les femmes le souhaitent et moi je pense
que c'est moins d'être discriminant au
contraire c'est une manière de remettre
le corps des femmes au sein du monde du
travail après il faudra quand même un
certificat médical on peut pas accorder
des des jours de congés maladie comme ça
sans certificat médical mais ça fera
partie des négociations de savoir
comment faire en sorte qu'il n'y ait pas
de discrimination vis-à-vis des femmes
et des douleurs qu'elle ressentent
[Musique]
alors Sandrine Rousseau dit on peut pas
se passer un certificat médical et
ensuite il faut trouver effectivement
des dispositifs pour qu'il n'y ait pas
de discrimination ça vous va comme
réponse pour l'instant c'est encore flou
c'est encore flou après la question
c'est de cette idée qu'il faut un
certificat médical c'est que on l'a dit
tout à l'heure il y a pas de test il y a
pas d'examen pour dire qu'il y a des
douleurs de règles donc moi je veux bien
écouter les femmes et faire un arrêt
maladie en disant il lui faut un congé
menstruel parce que elle a mal au ventre
mais est-ce qu'on pourrait pas se dire
que les femmes en autonomie peuvent
rapporter leurs douleurs et peut-être je
sais pas avec des filières directement
sur sur la médecine du travail ou je il
y a probablement des choses à réinventer
de ce côté là mais de faire confiance
finalement aux femmes sur le fait que
elles vont pas dire qu'elles ont mal si
elles ont pas mal quoi alors il y a
encore des dispositifs à préciser
peut-être des dispositifs législatives à
mettre en place mais enfin ça avance
ça avance très vite quand même dans le
débat public on en parle alors moi je
trouve ça très bien qu'on en parle parce
qu'on parlait de lever les tabous bah
oui on lève les tabous on en parlant
après dans les pays qui l'ont mis en
place le Japon l'a mis en place il y a
très longtemps et aujourd'hui il est
très très peu utilisé ce qu'on aime on
se réel donc pourquoi elle l'utilise pas
parce que si elle l'utilise ça risque
d'être encore plus discriminant et là où
elles sont déjà maltraitées au travail
est-ce que ça va pas augmenter cette
maltraitance au travail exactement donc
ça n'est pas forcément l'outil n'est pas
forcément
précieux pour les femmes il faut que
tout le reste suive et notamment les
mentalités c'est ça c'est ça l'idée
merci beaucoup beaucoup Perrine Gousseau
cap mas d'avoir été notre invité
aujourd'hui merci de nous avoir suivis à
très vite sur la chaîne parlementaire
LCP
[Musique]
Assemblée nationale en partenariat avec
mgeen mutuelle santé prévoyance vous a
présenté état de santé